my two favorite scenes are the one of
mac and Charlie brainstorming the idea
for the movie it's just so funny and it
really capped cappers that feeling in a
writer's room where you feel like you
get on a roll and then you're all like
firing and people are throwing out yes
and you're getting so excited about it
and then that one person goes a little
too far and you're like wow you're like
with me watching that to be like this
kind of does mirror our relationship how
many times have we been in a room
pitching ideas and getting each other
excited about an idea many many times
for many many years we know
this are cool what if he's a scientist
okay a muscular scientist I'm into that
right as long as we don't cover up that
body with lab coat bro dude he's wearing
like a hot mesh tank top I like that now
does he like fight crime or something
yeah yeah he fights crime uh with his
brain and his brawn
should we be writing this down all right
people only have the realization at the
same time we've got something here and
we gotta get it up here yeah